and welcome today's presentation what
i'm talking about today is how to spot
order flow trading opportunities you
know these are uh great times to be in
the markets
you know the last uh since last friday
markets had a lot of volatility a lot of
movement up a lot of movement down more
importantly over the last several days
and today is is no different so
what i'm only talking about is
opportunities that other traders don't
see you know when
when traders
you know go on twitter and
social media you always see this quote
to be successful you have to have an
edge well
it
they don't really tell you how to
find your edge right they just say you
know it's just a blanket statement which
everybody says i mean there is truth to
it you know you have to find something
that works for you that
is going to give you an advantage over
other people you know it's just like
whether you're playing
a sport right you have to be good at
certain thing you know if um
you know they say you play football
right american football you know
if you're good at a certain position
that's your edge right if you play poker
you know being able to tell um you know
what other players are doing that's
going to give you an edge and it's no
different in the market there's
different ways to find edges
so what i'm going to share with you
today is about how i developed my edge
in the markets with order flow and it's
from order flow that
you can spot more trading opportunities
right i'm here to help you you know
that's why i love doing these
presentations with investors expo is
because it gives me a chance to share
with everybody
you know my experience right and if
you're new to one of my presentations
let me just give you a brief brief
background on who i am right i'm not
somebody that just you know took up
trading a few years ago and think you
know oh you know i'm in the middle of a
bull market that you know i'm the next
warren buffett no you know i've got over
25 years professional trading experience
i started on the cme
uh floor literally at the bottom
you know as a runner right which is you
know the lowest job you can get on the
cme floor that was back in the 1990s and
as the electronic trading started
growing and becoming in my opinion was
going to be the next big thing
nobody didn't expect all the floors to
close up as quickly as they did i
eventually left the floor and started
trading on the upstairs trading desk
back in the 90s when globex
on the cme started
really gaining a strong foothold and you
know chicago board of trade had what
they call project a
nymex access or sorry nymex comex had
their electronic trading system called
access
and you know i started doing that for
several years and i realized you know
this is where the future is going to be
i got to
really you know immerse myself in it
after three years that dean witter i
joined
the english trading company edf man in
chicago on their global macro futures
trading desk
i spent about two years there before
joining the big german bank commerce
bank we had a desk in chicago and we had
the one of a handful maybe i think there
was like six or eight
actual ux trading terminals in the
united states
and then the cftc put a moratorium on
them because they didn't want the
competition so you know back in the late
90s i was one of literally just a
handful of people trading
on
the ux exchange in the u.s
then you know after september 11th i
took some time off then i joined cargill
the big commodity trading firm which
just regained
top position as
the um
largest privately held company in the
united states
and just put that in perspective if it
was a public company it'd probably be
ranked 7th or eighth as
the biggest public company in the us but
you know they account for most of the
grain exports in the us and i say most i
mean you know about 30 percent you know
meat exports about 25
and
they sent me out to singapore when the
exchange was closing down there or not
closing down but the floor rather was
closing down it was going electronic and
they wanted someone with electronic
trading experience that can set up a
trading desk there that's how i ended up
in singapore and after setting that up i
joined jp morgan i spent eight years
there at jpmorgan as vice president of
futures trading
and these are actual trading jobs
you know banging away on the trading
system you know every day buying and
selling you know it's not like i was
just
you know sitting in an office somewhere
looking at spreadsheets no you know i
was there trading seeing what the effect
of an order would have on the market
you know doing all the stuff that
traders do i left jpmorgan in 2013 and
a few years later you know while i was
trading for myself i started
a company called orderflows.com
now
the reason i'm telling you that is
because you know the charts that you're
going to see are generated from the
order flows trader software and it runs
on ninjatrader so in 2015 i released the
original order flows trader software
which is
software designed to help traders
understand what's happening in the order
flow
okay so we have pre-programmed tools in
it that will help you
not just see the order flow but really
understand what is going on
in the order flow it's one thing to be
able to see the order flow but if you
can't make heads or tails of it it's not
going to be of any use to you
so again you know the charts and tools
that are used in this training are
generated from my overflow software
and but what i'm showing you today you
can be
using it with you know there's a lot of
other software out there that already
has footprint charts so if you're using
another software
hopefully you can take what you've
learned today and apply it to the
software you're already using because
now you know what to look for and i'm
going to show you how you can quickly
and easily
apply order flow analysis to your
trading so you can make better informed
trades
now if you stick around to the end
you know i realize that a lot of people
you know sometimes this is all new
information to them and it just feels
like you're drinking from a fire hose so
i'm going to show you how to get a copy
of my book trading order flow it's 150
page book you're not going to get a hard
copy you're going to get the digital
download
but you're going to get it for free
right because you know that's my way of
giving back to the trading community
now you know just a brief disclaimer we
all know trading involves risk you
should only
trade with risk capital that
could be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle don't
don't go trading with money you can't
afford to lose in other words so why
order flow
all right so what attracted me to
orderflow years ago when i say years ago
i'm talking about in the 90s was being
able to see things happening in the
market that other traders just don't see
you know just seeing an order come into
the market right when there was a old
when there was a trading floor you know
open outcry of the pit
you can see the orders coming into the
market
then when we went
started going electronic and i had the
actual cme globex trading terminal in
front of me i could see the orders
hitting the order book and getting
executed
right if you were just looking at a cqg
back then there wasn't many quote
systems out there it's like cqg thompson
reuters
dtn
and you just see the print go through
but being on a native terminal i was
able to see what was coming in
what was trading nowadays you could you
get all that information on
pretty much any front-end trading system
and not a lot of people are using it you
know a lot of people are still stuck on
following the price on a chart but what
i'm going to show you is how to dig
deeper
into that chart
and analyze the information that's
available to you
right because it's with the order flow
that you're going to be able to
understand why a market moved when
seemingly there was no reason for that
movement right or why the market stopped
at a particular level okay so for
example
this was you know two days ago this was
in the e-minis right we had a big
sell-off overnight
and the market started selling off then
it rallied back up
right up to this level 46.40 and then it
tanked well
you know as a trader right you always
want to know you know
oh i wish i could have sold it over here
well if you knew what happened in the
order flow you can see just by looking
to the left
if there was anything here right and i'm
going to show you how using software
is going to help you do that
because you know if you could get in up
here right you know with with a very
what i call a low risk trade
you know put in a an offer up here at
46.40
while it's trading down here at 4 600
you just you have an offer sitting up
there you know with you know two or
three points stop
to catch that 40-50 point move down
and if you're looking at the order flow
you will know
that
you know up here at
46.45 you know over here at 46
35 there was very aggressive selling and
as a trader what you're going to want to
see
is when the market comes back to those
areas where you had the aggressive
selling earlier
all right first time you came back up to
this 46 um what is that 46 35ish area
you know the market hit came off a bit
sort of struggled around there then went
back up through it to this next level up
here
tested it came off you know doesn't look
like much but this is actually a move of
um
you know about almost 20 points right
here this little move
because you know it was just a gigantic
move this day
but then you know it came right back up
again tested that level again and sold
off so what's that telling you is you
know
the first time there's still
sellers up here right
came back up you're still expecting
sellers up here right and the market
sold off again you're not risking you
know 20 points or anything you just
throwing an offer up in here you know
with you know a point or two
risk you don't need to
risk such big amounts right but it's
giving you
a nice entry to catch a nice move
down
so order flow is based on what's
happening in right now in the market
right it's based on the trading that's
happening
and it's based more importantly on the
present right not the past so
you know even though i say it's not
based on the past you know there's a
level here from the past but as we're
coming up is the market confirming that
it's rejecting these levels right when i
say you're trading in the present
as the market comes up to a level
whether it's based on order flow or you
know your own type of level that you
determine watching how the market reacts
in the order flow it's going to give you
an edge over
other traders because you can see
whether that level is being rejected or
being accepted or if we're going to go
right through it
so
what benefits traders more is analyzing
what's happening right now in the market
based on what's trading right now and
that's where a lot of traders sort of
miss a step
okay they they think that well i have my
level that's all that i need well really
you got to start watching what happens
when the market reaches your level
right is the market going to
react to it or not right i mean not you
know one of the problems with people
with technical analysis they think it
always has to work 100 of the time it
doesn't
and if you've ever studied technical
analysis you know maybe you know there's
all these different formations and
patterns
you know some of the best ones maybe
work about 60 percent 65 percent of the
time that's not a very good
winning percentage per se but
more importantly you can increase that
level
by seeing what is happening in the
market in the order flow as you reach a
specific level
in
the order flow okay so
in order flow right there's three main
building blocks there's delta point of
control and imbalances
okay and most order flow software will
show you all that
but
i wanted an easier way to analyze that
market generated information rather than
just put it right in front of my face
that's why i created my own software the
order flows traders 3.0
which takes the information that you see
in the time the sales and depth of
market and transforms it into an easy to
read
format
okay because you know it's not like
everyone when everyone thinks of mobile
phones they think of the iphone steven
jobs didn't invent the mobile phone he
just took the existing technology and
made it better
right by improving it
and that's sort of what i wanted to do
with order flow right i wanted to take
the existing technology and improve it
to help me with
my analysis
now have you ever stopped and thought
about how your chart is constructed most
people don't they think oh you know it's
based on you know high and low and you
know and it is it's basic right this is
your basic candlestick chart red bars
green bars okay and you got your wicks
you got so you got your open your high
your low your clothes right but where
does all this information come from well
it comes from the time and sales right
it's the record of every trade that
occurs on the exchange
there's a time stamp there's a volume
stamp
it tells you what how it traded whether
it's on the bid or the offer honestly i
didn't really
um it took me a while to really
appreciate the value of that information
what was trading on the bid or what was
trading on the offer i remember the old
um
cbot project a system would show the
aggressor of a trade meaning you know if
the bond market was you know 1617 and
someone bought 100 at at 17.
that was
valuable information i didn't really at
the time i'm like yeah i don't really
need to see that but over once i started
processing it and understanding it
because you know in the past when there
would be a big offer or a big bid i'd
always just sell one into it so i could
see who's the who's that on the other
side but then when i realized hey now i
can see who the aggressor is right who's
selling the hundred into the bid or
who's buying 500 you know from the offer
that was good information and it's the
same thing even though now you don't see
the counterparty but you can see
you know who's
which side is is more aggressive
so
a footprint chart the basic footprint
chart has you know your delta which is
the difference between aggressive buying
and aggressive selling it's got your
point of control which is your level
with the most
volume
it's got imbalances right so it's
telling you
you know the price level
or in the two-way auction that has you
know more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling
but that's just the basic software
and it had been that way for about 10
years
but i would always you know do my own
analysis right
and i know a computer can help me
by doing that analysis for me right i
could unders read
the importance of certain imbalances
where they appear in a bar where does
point of control appear in a bar um you
know how is delta shaping up in a bar
and things like that right so as you can
see there's just so much more
information you still have
you know your candlestick right you
still know where the market opened where
it closed what the high the low is in
the bar but now
able to take it a step further right i
can see where traders are being more
aggressive at a certain time or a
certain price
you know if there's a big support level
in the market or if what is trading is
forming a support level right so
again you know there's more to it than
just seeing delta imbalances and point
of control you got to start putting
those pieces together you know it's a
bit like
a puzzle
so
when traders first learn about order
flow they just learn what delta is what
point of control is what imbalances are
and that's good you need to know that
but then they're sort of left to figure
out
what does that mean you know how to put
these pieces of information together
and
you know it's it's
it's difficult for people honestly you
know it's like i've got kids who are
taking um
you know lessons like right now they're
in swimming lessons and you know they're
trying to learn you know the importance
of you know this is the stroke
why do you need to use that and when do
you need to use it and it's just the
same as you know delta or point of
control and imbalances you don't use it
all at once you know you use imbalances
at this
particular point or you want to look at
point of control here or you want to
know what delta is doing here
right so you got to know how to use it
so what i'm going to show you is again
it can be done by just looking at any
footprint chart i'm going to show you on
my footprint chart and i'm going to show
you some of the tools that i've
developed to you know make it a little
bit easier
because
when the market is moving just like
today you know i said yesterday but
today it's it's up and down right
yesterday also up and down and it's easy
to miss things right because the
market's moving so fast sometimes you
get excited if you're watching you know
the dome price is just jumping up and
down you're going to easily overlook
things and miss things
so
yeah i'm a big believer and let the
trading software do the heavy lifting
for you and show you things
in the order flow all right like whether
it's market weakness or market strength
right or price rejection
because after all order flow is about
understanding what traders are doing in
the market right
you need an easy way to process that
information
don't make trading too difficult that
you can't understand what's happening
right
but again you know you got to know how
to connect the dots right you got to
know when to use delta when to use point
of control when to use imbalances right
and how to put them together
all right so
a common
understanding of market theory is that
markets move from balance to imbalance
to balance
it's basic right but what traders fail
to often consider is what happens when
the market moves back to its previous
imbalance right because
you know literally for the last
year markets just been you know straight
up almost well not straight up but on a
45 degree line
but you know markets retrace all the
time
right they come back to previous
areas of imbalance they just go from
balance to balance you know sometimes
they go back to an imbalance area
and
again this is just yesterday a lot of
these are this is just last night you
know 12 hours ago
and we hit our high market came off and
rallied right back up to this level here
45 34
and then stole off a bit you know good
five six points it's eight o'clock last
night
that's because
there was aggressive selling interest
there right we had just hit the high
and what we have here is what we call a
stack selling a balance right this is
order flow 101 stack selling a balance
very nice neat easy to see right you
have imbalances in the order flow 30
against zero right in the two-way
auction at this price 34 against 34 and
a quarter 30 straight down the bid
nothing on the offer
33 and three quarters three seven lots
versus one at thirty four
thirty three and a half six versus zero
at three and three quarters so what you
have is the stacked sound of bounces you
have three cell and a balances all
neatly stacked on top of each other
right and then you have this zone drawn
out now our software will draw the zone
out until the price comes back up to
that area
so you can see market sold off came
circled right back up here hit this area
and we got through it doesn't
necessarily mean it has to stop right on
that area when the market's a little bit
more volatile like today sometimes you
you breach the area by a few ticks and
then you continue in that direction but
imagine you're sitting in here with an
offer you know at 33 and a half
you know a stop
maybe a point two points point and a
half higher
you know 35 35 and a half
you could have easily just gotten a
quick
five points
right over the next five minutes it just
came up that area came off and you're
only risking you know point and a half
two points two points
to get
you know
what five points that's a two to one
risk to reward ratio
right this is also this is yesterday
during the day session right market's
coming off right bounces back up just
sort of stops here at this 41 ish area
goes sideways boom boom boom
and then sells off
10 points well why
what was happening here you know this is
not an area where it's like oh you had
some uh resistance coming in here or
here or here you know people say well
you gotta draw this line up from here no
you don't just look at the order flow
because earlier as the market was
selling off you had the stacks on a
balance here
right in here at 41. right you just have
an offer sitting in here at 41.
right it's
you know with
a stop at you know 42 42 and a half 43.
it's going to give you a nice you know
look at that it sold off from 41 all the
way down to 30.
again you're just risking you know a
point and a half two points
to get five ten points out of the market
okay
it looks a lot looks very similar to the
previous chart i just showed you right
it just but this is a different this is
later in the day this is around uh 12 30
yesterday the first chart i showed you
was 10 30 alright markets coming off
comes right back up sort of stops around
this area up in here around you know
0.607
and then it sells off
right down in here all right another 10
points
well why
you have this stacks on a balance right
here
right it's
again it don't make trading so
complicated right this is a very basic
very easy to see very visual thing to
see on your chart again
you know you just you throw an offer in
here
at you know 0607 to stop at eight and a
half nine
even in the next in that area there's
one bar you could have sold those sevens
and covered it down almost at double o
you know you could have got your five
points right in this one bar alone
now
market sold off right we sold all the
way down to you know at this time was
around 80.
all right well why did the market stop
here and all of a sudden
rally
right it rallied from
the 80 area all the way up to 95. well
earlier
as from the day before actually
you had
aggressive buying interest at this area
it took you know almost the whole
session to come back to that level
but imagine you know if you just you
know this level right this is the level
you saw yesterday finally got back down
to that area
reached it by a couple ticks but again
if you're buying it in here at
you know you got to stop at
you know 77 and a half or even 76
boom it just rallied right up it's a
nice strong move up right came all the
way back down right we're trading 46
what was the high yesterday like 46.50
came all the way down finally hit that
area then we rallied almost immediately
a quick
um you know 15 20 points
now stacked imbalances are nice right
they're very visual very easy to see
but every order flow trader
can easily spot it right and there's
nothing wrong with that because it's
good because you want other people to
see what you're seeing and do the same
thing because that's going to help you
get those moves
right you're not going to
it's going to be difficult if you're
always trying to swim against everybody
so to speak right if you think you have
a magic way of finding your own levels
but nobody else is seeing those then
those levels probably aren't going to
work for you
because there's nobody else behind or
selling based off of levels that you're
seeing what you want to see is some
things that are very visual that other
traders are going to jump in and give
the market that momentum
but the other thing i want to talk about
is multiple imbalances
in bars so what i call multiple
imbalance bars
and
they're just bars that have
like three or more imbalances but
they're not necessarily stacked neatly
on top of each other to give you a nice
neat stacked imbalance think of it this
way think of it as as you know an
imbalanced turning point
so
this was crude oil yesterday right low
of the day
right then we rallied 50 cents in 15
minutes right a nice a nice quick rally
well what's happening down here at the
low of the day
well you have a bar in here with
three buying imbalances right boom
that's your trigger telling you hey you
know what aggressive buyers are stepping
in even the next bar had
um it was about five buying and balances
in it right so you know that
there's that momentum now buying
momentum in the market
because you have the aggressive trading
coming in so that's your clue again
you're not trying to predict the bottom
but once you see the aggressive buying
come in you say hey you know what maybe
this bottom can hold
and i could i could buy because where's
your stop going to be it's going to be
at the you know just below the low
because if you take out that low
then this aggressive buying doesn't
you know
the whole premise for getting long off
this aggressive bind is no longer there
but when you buy then you start seeing
more aggressive buying coming in
you know that's what you want to see you
don't want to see aggressive selling
coming in if you're trying to buy
this was gold yesterday uh sorry this
was gold monday
right
got five dollar rally after the low has
been established well
what can you see in this low that's you
know going to give you a clue well you
got a bar with
one two three
four five six seven binder balances in
it
all right that's your clue that you know
what the aggressive buyers have finally
stepped into the market maybe this
market could finally start moving higher
right then you just sort of see in the
next few bars sort of go sideways
but more importantly you don't have that
aggressive selling move in the market
down you're still seeing some signs of
aggressive buying before it finally pops
up and you know makes a nice five dollar
move
this is japanese yen
okay you're at the high of the day
88.87 and then the market sells off
all the way down to you know almost uh
almost 88.00
but what's happening up in here right
this is where looking at the order flow
is just going to give you that extra
advantage over other people
you'll notice it hits this high does it
comes back towards it can't get up there
before it suddenly starts grinding its
way a little bit lower then boom the
bottom just falls out but
as clear as day here on on a footprint
chart
if you're looking at the order flow
you've got multiple imbalances in here
one two three four
right you'll notice
what the software does is it puts a box
around the bar it's not brain surgery
you know i like to call it oh this is
the order flow imbalance algo no it's
not you know it's simple you know
there's people out there that will you
know try and sell you a bag of beans
but it's really just
simple right it's simple tools to make
trading
easier right you got the box around
there telling you
that you have aggressive selling coming
into the bar
right now
you're at the high of the day
you always want to be asking yourself is
is this market going to go keep going
higher is it going to react off this and
sell off well when you start seeing the
aggressive buying i show you aggressive
selling coming in
you should
you know put that thought that the
market's going to go higher sort of on
the back burner because you have
aggressive selling
at the high of the day just as in the
gold earlier
aggressive buying coming in at the low
of the day right
crude oil aggressive buying coming in at
the low of the day you know going into
the lows you're expecting to see
aggressive selling and you see these
bars multiple imbalances
multiple imbalances multiple imbalances
even this bar multiple imbalances
right
that's what you see these purple these
magenta boxes around but finally you see
the green candle the up candle
with
the purple box on you the aggressive
buying is coming in but it's spread out
in the bar right it's not neatly stacked
neatly three in a row on top of each
other
you know this gold one is spread out as
well you get
seven imbalances but they're really
spread out in the bar
so again if the market's moving quickly
it's not something you're going to
necessarily notice that oh yeah there's
a lot of buying balances in here that's
why we just simply put the
box around there to sort of help your
training
become easier
now
things i want to talk about here now is
is
something that you it deals with delta
in the bar right delta is the difference
between aggressive buying and aggressive
selling in a bar
and this is a way to see trapped traders
right by using the delta everyone talks
about trap trade all you know there's
trap traders in the market they'll look
at a normal
um bar chart
and they'll say oh there's trap traders
here well how can you tell right so well
price is rejected because i got a wick
here or something like that they're just
all hypotheses right they're just
guessing
and oftentimes you're guessing it well
after the fact that it happened
so
when you're looking at delta and trying
to determine if there's trapped traders
now this is a bit more advanced but you
don't need any fancy tools to see it
just an order flow footprint chart and
we'll show you how to see it in here now
this is a five minute chart
and
you can see this red bar here
red bar here right normally when you're
seeing down candles red candles right
down bars you expect to see
negative delta
right like see red candle here negative
delta minus three thousand
another red candle
uh minus two thousand but this one's got
positive delta one fifty 154 is another
one here
positive delta
uh
765. this is other one here also the one
in the middle i didn't mark it's got
positive delta of 125.
but the important ones are are these two
all right because market sold off came
back up market sold off came back up
starts coming back down a little bit
but you have positive delta well how can
the market go down on positive delta
well the reason is going down on
positive delta is because you have
supply in the market in this case in
this red candle so people were buying it
expecting this market to go higher so
someone was absorbing that buying so
those buyers that those aggressive
buyers are getting trapped in the market
right they're
you know i don't say you know someone is
trying to trap them but rather you know
they're sort of
doing it to themselves they're they're
buying it in hopes the market is going
up because there's somebody there
absorbing all their buying
that's what's causing the positive delta
now you can see here i have the ask
volume and the bid volume
these top two numbers so it's 12 586
was the volume on you know the
aggressive buyers whereas the aggressive
sellers was 12 40
12 432 that's why you only end up with
154.
similar thing in this other bar
so the market sold off
you know this was a quick sell-off of
about
you know
over 15 points this is a five minute
e-mini chart came back up starts selling
off and as you're coming back down
there's people offering it in here
there's supply you could look at the
footprint you can see well you know 1200
traded here
that's one of the reasons why you got
such a big positive delta but when it
hit this level
45.90 there's a big seller there
right someone's got supply so everyone
that was buying it because you can
remember the market just rallied about
15 points people are thinking hey
you know
it's going to go higher right market
just went all the way up to
you know 96 97 it's coming back down
six points lower hey you know i could
buy it because i think this mark
market's going back up but there's
someone in there offering it out
they're buying it they can't sustain
that move market drops right market
drops come sort of back up towards that
level over the next three bars before
falling over
but that is a sign when you see these
red candles with the positive delta or a
green candle with negative delta which
i'll show you in a minute
all right those are often signs of
supply
coming into the market right or
absorption in other words coming into
the market
this is what it looked like on the
candlestick chart yesterday right you
can't tell that there was
you know people getting trapped up in
here they started doing it again
they're doing it to themselves thinking
the market's going to finally start to
rally but there's you know bigger
traders there that have a lot of supply
happy to sell it to them all day long
and we know what happened with the
market yesterday going into the close
now here's
another example this is
monday at 30th or tuesday rather
excuse me
you rally all the way up to a swing high
positive delta 447.
okay you got positive delta why is the
market selling off well it's because
early in this bar
people are excited thinking this market
is is going higher
but it can't sustain that move
right so there was people up here happy
to sell it to these
willing buyers people here take my money
think this market's going up
once that russia buying
ended
what happened
the one but there's no more buyers
the market is just going to fall
naturally this is what it did right it
was a nice move 4600 all the way down to
45.90 quick 10 point move so one minute
chart over one two three four five
six minutes
another example this is crude oil
yesterday right again swing high big
positive delta 123
why it's because market rallied up
people are thinking hey this rally's you
know i gotta get in fomo
get me in okay they got in
well unfortunately that was the end of
the move
the sign is right here the red candle
the down candle with the positive delta
at the swing high
mark you dropped literally in the next
three minutes four minutes
you know almost
75 cents
right quickly right it's not something
you're
sitting there trying to you know wait
all day for these are
you know when you're dealing with order
flow the moves can happen very quickly
all right it's not something that's just
going to sort of meander now earlier you
had a bar here there's a red candle
kind of at a swing high
it's sold off a little bit you know not
the dramatic sell-off that you have here
but then it just sort of went sideways
before coming back up you know people
say well yeah you had you know you had
this one trade here and it was maybe a
loser right i mean i don't know maybe
you could have scalped a few ticks out
of it
noticing that was coming back up you
know maybe you scratched it
but really what you're looking for with
the overflow is the move to happen fast
it doesn't happen within the next couple
of bars
chances are it's not going to really
happen
but again are you willing to
take this
trade here
this is a trade i would take
okay it didn't work out you scratch the
trade maybe you lose five cents you take
the next one boom it's never really
against you once you get in once this
market starts dropping here you get in
doesn't come all the way back up here it
doesn't test the high just immediately
moves the way it's supposed to move
this was again crude oil now this was on
the low yesterday
okay
what do you see here what you see
negative delta it's an up candle it's a
green candle so what's that telling you
you had
supportive buying in that market you
could see it in here 78 70 70 you know
you're seeing some strong bids in here
so aggressive sellers are selling into
these bids these bidders were happy to
to absorb all their all their selling
but once you know these guys are done
selling there's nobody left to sell what
do you think is going to happen
well market's going to rally back up
right this time it rallied another 75
cents
in about 15 minutes
now you know a lot of the examples i
show you is i at the highs or lows swing
highs or swing lows or highs a day lows
of the day but you have to understand it
can happen anywhere now
i don't like to just take it because it
happened right you've got a red bar with
positive delta or a green bar with a
negative delta i like to put it in
context right so if i can see
you know sort of a market is sort of
topping out and start coming down you
know i'll take it not necessarily in the
middle of a move
but that's why i like to see them at
highs or lows swing highs or swing lows
this was like an hour ago this was in
the s ps
right market
shot up
and then sold off
right what do you have up here at this
swing high clear swing high
positive delta
right there was
aggressive buying in here
but there was also
met with supply
right there are traders they're happy to
absorb
all their buying
then the market
did once you know did what it's going to
do once that aggressive buying
uh finishes
then you'll notice right after that what
do you see bars with multiple imbalances
you're seeing stacked selling imbalances
so not only do you have
you know traders that are trapped up
here but then as the market starts
moving
you know there's
lighter fluid is thrown onto the fire in
terms of
imbalances stacked imbalances multiple
imbalances telling you that hey you know
what sellers are coming into the market
and coming in strong
so even if you you know you're like well
you know i'm not sure about this high
once you start seeing the the aggressive
selling coming in in this bar and you're
getting in here you know at 46
you know just a quick 10 points in in
five minutes
this morning you know so
hopefully
you can see things and how to use it now
you can see you know what the importance
of of delta what the importance is of
imbalances i even touched on point of
controls i mean that's a whole another
training session
but if you're interested in that you
know go to my youtube channel
i got a lot of information on
how to understand what's happening in
the order flow with point of control as
well
so remember right the information you
see on your bar charts come from what's
traded
in the market right what you see in the
time and sales but candlestick chart
your bar chart leaves out the most
important
part of data the volume traded on the
bid the volume that's traded on the
offer
and more importantly how to imply how to
use it right because you know it's one
thing to have that information you got
to know how to use it and
you got to format it as well right and
that's what the footprint chart does is
it helps you format the data so that you
can
use it and analyze it so you know always
trade in context of the market
that's what being a trader is all about
right you don't just go out and start
trading every bar that a multiple
imbalance appears put it in context of
the market don't go out and trade every
bar that has a diverging delta put it in
context of the market
you know that's to me that's sort of
the holy grail of trading is putting the
information that you're seeing in
context right it's not that you know
every time you see an instance of
something happening in the market that
you just got to go and uh
take that trade no you got to
put the puzzle piece in the puzzle right
that's how you're going to solve it
so
in the past 40 minutes i hope you're
going to agree it's been time well spent
but again i can't cover everything in a
60-minute training session or even a
40-minute training session
so but i got a special offer that you
get everything you need to know about
order flow and if you act fast i'll give
you a very special deal and you know
earlier i talked about the order flows
trader 3.0 and again you saw the charts
that i used in the presentation are
generated from the order flows trader
3.0 and it works on ninjatrader 8.
it's not available for other platforms
it's ninjatrader 8 right now
and it's the volume footprint chart with
17 pre-programmed order flow tools i
talked about the multiple imbalances
tool
today
that's just one of them right and
you know i like software that's easy to
use i don't like to buy software and
just have to spend an afternoon trying
to figure it out it really is it takes
about two minutes to set the whole thing
up you don't need templates or anything
like that
because the default settings are
defaulted for an e-mini one-minute chart
which is where you know most traders
start
and its normal price is 899 dollars
and
you're not going to pay that today but
really what the order flows trader is
like it's like taking
you know a hdmi cable plugging it into
my brain right so you can see
what the install trader institutional
traders are doing in the market right
because you want to know
you know these areas of importance in
the market
now having order flow software is one
thing you still got to know how to use
it right so
i provide a lot of further education
on how to trade with order flow
so
again if you take my special deal today
you can get access to my order flow
trading course which i normally sell for
297.
you can get that for free but unless
also throw in access to my inner circle
video series which is 56 advanced order
flow
videos talking about little tips
analysis and tricks
so if you had the software the training
and the video series that's already
almost seventeen hundred dollars
now i i realize it's one thing to learn
from videos and books but it takes
discipline and commitment you know sit
down and watch this i've got a lot of
courses i've bought that i've never been
watched
so what i found very helpful is provide
live training where you can come in and
ask questions so for the last two or
three years i've been doing a live user
session every tuesday night where i
drive home what i see in the order flow
for the past week you can ask your
questions
and you know areas that you're going to
be struggling in your analysis now it's
free for all users there's over 100 and
there's 146 videos in there so it gives
you an idea of how long i've been doing
this for
you know it's every week so i'm at 100
week 146.
some companies want to charge you extra
for that training we give it to you for
free
so you know you're already pushing about
eighteen hundred dollars nineteen
hundred dollars for all this but you're
going to get it for just a one-time
payment of 7.49 you just got to go to
order flows
dot com slash off three
and
you just click on the link in there
put it in the chat there for people
there's no monthly recurring payments or
any other payments in the future of
course you do need a real-time data feed
but again you know what other people are
saying about the software is you know
it's been remarkably helpful i can
clearly see now
what's happening in the market right and
really that's what you want to do is you
want to understand what you're seeing in
the market
so you just go to orderflows.com
off three o f t the number three dot
html page looks like this scroll down
get to the page
click here to buy now again i got some
other instructional videos and examples
that you can take a look at
and you're gonna see it's just a
one-time payment of 749 takes you to
paypal
it's processed through paypal
which everyone has i don't want your
credit card information i don't need it
it's just a one-time payment
and as a special bonus for
people that came in through investors
expo and give you access to the order
flow playbook which is one of my
favorite courses that i've made
it's got a bunch of trade setups in
there that you can also look for in the
order flow normally it's 297 you're
going to get it for free
so get started i just go to
orderflows.com off three so what you're
going to get the order flows trader
software the trading course the inner
circle video series access to the weekly
group training
and the playbook but again it's just a
one-time payment
749.
to get my book just go to orderflows.com
book.html enter your name
email address
and it takes you to the next page to
where you can download it so
get started right just go to
orderflows.com3.html
all right anna um you know i don't have
time for questions but i put the links
in the chat if anybody's got any
questions just shoot me an email it's
mike orderflows.com
so i'll throw it back to you anna thanks
for having me
you're welcome
you